[Música]
porque con nuestra primera invitada el
día vamos a hablar de la situación de
seguridad de ecuador sobre todo en la
ciudad costera de guayaquil esto tras el
atentado bomba del pasado domingo 14 de
agosto que acabó con la vida de cinco
personas y dejó un saldo de 17 personas
heridas guayaquil es una de las ciudades
más pobladas de ecuador con unos 3
millones de habitantes y además es el
puerto de comercio exterior de esa
nación los residentes de la urbe han
experimentado una ola de violencia y
también delitos relacionados con las
bandas criminales como asesinatos entre
rivales por el control del narcotráfico
y también enfrentamientos con armas de
fuego una de las líneas de investigación
indica que este ataque estaba dirigido a
dos hombres con el área de cucaracha y
juniors miembros de la banda delictiva
'los art y querer tirones que sabemos de
esta banda como ópera y está actualmente
violencia organizada en ecuador como
está afectando a la población pues le
preguntamos a nuestra primera invitada
al día ya es maría fernanda torres
magister en relaciones internacionales
convención en seguridad por la facultad
latinoamericana de ciencias sociales
especialista en seguridad de
inteligencia gracias por estar con
nosotros maría fernanda esta mañana de
jueves en directo américa de france 24
hablemos entonces del crimen organizado
en el cuadro del control de la
exportación de las drogas desde ese país
sobre todo la región costera en la
ciudad de guayaquil
como estará un muy buenos días un saludo
para usted y para su distinguida
audiencia
efectivamente como es conocido a nivel
mundial se ha producido un incremento en
la producción de droga esto
evidentemente también afecta a lo que es
ecuador sin embargo los recientes
eventos aún cuando las autoridades
oficiales lo relacionan directamente
tiene que ver con una condición social
que se ha venido deteriorando en los
últimos años de nuestro país ahora
digamos que el estado de excepción en la
zona costera que tan
bien le ha hecho a esta zona realmente
ha sido efectiva de hamás que tan
apetecida en esta zona por los grupos de
criminales nuestra que con traficantes
en un estado de excepción en términos
generales como su nombre lo indica
debería ser colocado o puesto cuando
existen eventos atípicos
desafortunadamente lo que estamos viendo
del último incidente
con las bombas no ha sido el único en el
país en el año llevamos registrado 145
eventos delictivos de esta naturaleza en
cuanto a qué tan apetecidos es la zona
para el narcotráfico pues evidentemente
guayaquil la ciudad de guayaquil es el
principal puerto marítimo de nuestro
país en consecuencia el tigre de
plataforma para el transporte de droga
hacia todo el exterior
maría fernanda porque el gobierno
ecuatoriano encabeza el presidente
guillermo lazo no realmente toma
acciones efectivas teniendo en cuenta lo
que usted dice que no es una situación
atípica que no es una situación aislada
esta bomba que vimos el pasado domingo
sino que esto ya viene siendo constante
lamentablemente para esta población de
guayaquil también la región de
esmeraldas que tengo entendido
sufre también de estos constantes pues
amenazas de este crimen organizado en
cuanto al narcotráfico
efectivamente uno de los mayores
problemas que se haya venido
evidenciando dentro del actual gobierno
y en general en los últimos dos
gobiernos es que ha faltado un tema de
planificación estratégica como está las
políticas en temas de seguridad han
venido siendo tratadas solamente a nivel
de gobierno es decir soluciones
temporales paños de agua tibia frente a
una fiebre que no termina de subir y que
no se está realmente atacando las causas
estructurales de este brote de violencia
e inseguridad
ahora estas bandas también operan desde
las cárceles además de estos episodios
de violencia en guayaquil
lamentablemente también hemos visto
estos motines carcelarios que ha acabado
con la vida de las personas no también
es el principal punto de encuentro de
estas bandas donde se disputan también
en todo este el narcotráfico pues el
liderazgo el narcotráfico dentro de las
cárceles que le hace falta también al
gobierno de ecuador para atacar
realmente a las cárceles porque
pareciera que el control digamos del
estado se le salió de las manos
y lo manejan los reclusos
efectivamente hay un tema importante de
que no se está brindando un tema de
rehabilitación social pero además
estudios independientes muestran hechos
por antropólogo nos muestran que el
problema tiene que ver con que muchas de
las fuentes humanas que se están
recolectando de la información que se
está recolectando para las incautaciones
de droga tiene que ver con puentes con
personas que se encuentran en cárceles
sin embargo no se mantiene la debida
cadena de custodia de la información
esta información está siendo liberada y
en consecuencia se produce este tema de
ajuste de cuentas una vez que de alguna
forma los grupos delincuenciales
entienden que se están liberando la
información desde la misma cárcel
también en los peticiones esta banda a
la que se le atribuye lo que pasó el
pasado domingo en guayaquil como opera
esta banda digamos o es que tan que tan
grande es esta organización criminal y
con que otras bandas se disputan el
control del narcotráfico sobre todo en
guayaquil que como lo estábamos hablando
es el puerto de salida de la droga
en los tirones están funcionando con
otras bandas delincuenciales
definitivamente no se puede saber qué
tan grandes son las bandas pero
efectivamente al saber que estamos
manejándonos en ámbitos del narcotráfico
sabemos que los recursos son limitados
sabemos que tienen contactos con otras
bandas internacionales del clan del
golfo y otras organizaciones tanto en
méxico como en colombia
también maría fernanda expertos estiman
que dentro de las cárceles se maneja un
comercio de unos 100 millones de dólares
en estas bandas criminales esto esto es
cierto
las estimaciones son e incluso me
atrevería a decir un poco conservadoras
porque se estima que en el país
alrededor del anualmente se están
lavando alrededor de 3.400 millones de
dólares
como el gobierno de ecuador estaría
atacando el narcotráfico o cómo podría
hacer para pues por digamos no
eliminarlo porque pues evidentemente es
un problema que va a tomar años de
eliminarlos si es que si es que lo
logran pero para tratar de mitigar sobre
todo la violencia que sufre la población
civil porque al final son los más
afectados no están en el medio de todas
estas disputas de estas bandas
delincuenciales estas bandas criminales
y sobre todo que se disputan el
narcotráfico como hacer realmente para
protegerlos no sé si también usted que
que es ecuatoriana ya se está dando
algún tipo de desplaza de desplazamiento
interno de las personas que tratan de
huir de esta violencia
afortunadamente al momento no es un tema
de desplazamiento mayor de grandes
cantidades de personas evidentemente si
de los criminales que huyen de su zona
de influencia a otras hacia otras zonas
ahora en cuanto a la pregunta que me
hacía qué puede hacer el gobierno
efectivamente lo que nos dice la técnica
es para combatir el narcotráfico no
solamente tenemos que trabajar en el
nivel de la de la respuesta sino que
también tenemos que trabajar mucho en el
tema de la previsión el trabajo de
inteligencia es fundamental para
determinar no solamente incautar y no sé
toneladas de drogas sino también
trabajar en los métodos de
financiamiento que tienen estas
organizaciones además es indispensable
reforzar todo el tema de barreras
físicas porque evidentemente sabemos que
frente a una frontera tan grande tan
permeable como tenemos tanto hacia el
nivel continental como hacia nivel
marítimo es indispensable que el
gobierno actualice los medios técnicos
para prevenir el contrabando de drogas
pero sobre todo también que haya un tema
de seguimiento porque muchas veces y en
lo que ha pasado en una de las grandes
dificultades es que se compra el
equipamiento pero con el cambio de
gobierno no se le da mantenimiento no se
actualizan los sistemas no se continúa
con la capacitación del personal
entonces lo primero y más importante
nosotros como ecuatorianos si contamos
con un marco jurídico adecuado pero lo
que nos está faltando son reglamentos de
leyes y a nivel ejecutivo la ejecución
de planes programas y proyectos que se
pongan de manifiesto frente a este
problema